comme en bourgogne durant trois nuits
les ignobles jurassiens ont souffert du
gel résigné il ne fait que constater les
dégâts
durant trois nuits denis grandvaux a
essayé notamment grâce à des bougies de
réchauffer les pieds de vigne mais rien
à faire
il estime la perte à près de 80% c'est
la grande catastrophe
on pense que ben là travailler va
pouvoir rien elle pire c'est qu'on va
travailler toute l'année pour rien on va
aller la mort au ventre avec travailler
nos vignes parce que ben faudra les
cultiver on sera obligé de les traiter
il faudra lire le v fera les palissé il
faudra le travail et pour pas en danger
de son côté damien petit n'a pas
beaucoup plus d'espoir mais il faudra
attendre deux ou trois semaines afin de
voir si quelques bourgeons ont résisté
aux grands froids pas assurés contre le
gel il réfléchit à faire la démarche
je pense que économe du coup monde sinon
une stabilité au niveau d'une entreprise
comme nous sur une stabilité et puis
avoir peur du lendemain
c'est peut-être une des solutions comme
damien au total dans le jura ce sont
près de 90% des vignerons qui ne sont
pas assurés contre le gel une démarche
coûteuse pour les viticulteurs qui n'y
retrouve pas forcément leur coûte faut
que le contrat proposé soit attractif or
pour qu'il soit attractif faut qu'on
travaille sur un potentiel de récolte et
non plus sur un historique parce que
aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme si on
vous disait votre maison
on va on vous avait assuré que la moitié
parce que l'autre moitié historiquement
l'a jamais brûlé après plusieurs années
difficiles marquées par des périodes
récurrente de gel et par l'aco vide
certains sont désespérés nous à la
société de viticulture on a eu une
réunion hier on parle déjà de créer une
cellule psychologique avec les services
de la préfecture
parce qu'il ya des jeunes viticulteurs
qui viennent de s'installer et puis qui
ont besoin de cette récolte pour
commencer à payer leurs charges et des
to et il n'y aura pas de tir a pas de
revenus les vignerons jurassiens espère
maintenant une aide de la part des
pouvoirs publics qui ont lancé depuis ce
matin le régime de calamité agricole